cette semaine on se plonge dans une
enquête policière qui porte notamment
sur des avocats devenus eux mêmes des
acteurs du crime organisé
décision cruciale était faite à son
bureau
donc le bureau était utilisé en sorte
comme un bouclier diviser une opération
de police délicate dans un cabinet
d'avocats quand soyons dans un bus j'ai
oublié un outil un à droite et que la
personne a trouvé une paire de pinces ou
à une bobine de vie
quatre heures et des acquittements au
nom du secret professionnel
alors que fait le bar pour moi c'est
honteux que le barreau ne prennent
aucune mesure pour faire en sorte qu'une
personne dont on connaît les activités
criminelles
soit encore membre de sa professeure et
pourquoi les avocats ne veulent pas être
soumis aux mêmes règles que les autres
professionnels pour lutter contre le
blanchiment d'argent
ce sont des avocats qui enquêtent sur
des avocats alors la question que je
peux aussi envers qui sont-ils imputable
est redevable ici marie maude denis
bienvenue à enquête
la plupart des gens sont honnêtes
tout comme la plupart des avocats
certains agissent tout au long de leur
carrière comme d'honorables fissiles
justice mais certains s'approchent
parfois de la ligne de la légalité dans
les conseils qu'il donne à leurs clients
certains la franchise carrément et
deviennent eux-mêmes des criminels mais
quoi qu'il en soit grâce aux privilèges
que leur confère la loi ce qui porte la
toge sont bien plus difficiles à
épingler
[Musique]
oui c'est bien lui vito rizutto le
parrain de la mafia est assis au fond de
l'avion l'air soulagé de sortir de
prison et de rentrer chez lui à montréal
il a passé les dernières années de
détenus au colorado pour sa
participation à un triple meurtre commis
à brooklyn en 1981
[Musique]
à sa descente d'avion la sécurité est
imposante autour de lui sa vie et
probablement menacée
[Musique]
trois ans plus tôt son fils nick a été
abattu en pleine rue
il toujours pendant qu'il était en
prison son père nicolo rizzuto a été
assassiné dans sa maison
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vito rizutto revient à montréal avec
deux bus venger la mort de ses proches
et reprendre le pouvoir qu'a perdu son
clan au sein du crime organisé à
montréal où rien ne va plus
[Musique]
à cette époque les incendies criminels
les tentatives et les meurtres se
succèdent
[Musique]
zut aux morts de cause naturelle avant
d'avoir remis son clan au pouvoir
il reste un fils risotto leonardo
risotto après la mort de son père
les policiers se demandent si suivra ses
traces et quelle place il prendra dans
le grand échiquier du crime
[Musique]
dans une fenêtre de l'autre côté de la
rue un policy photographier les andelys
les clichés seront examinées de près
parce qu'une enquête importante est en
cours depuis un an le projet mag au
magot c'est une enquête menée par
l'escouade régionale mixte de là et ce
qu assister de la grc depuis un an une
vingtaine de suspects de différentes
factions criminels sont dans la mire
leurs conversations sont écoutés leurs
messages blackberry décrypter la police
continue de courir les funérailles comme
celle d'un influent membre des hells
angels en septembre 2012
c'est là qu'ils ont toute une surprise
un duo improbable arrivent ensemble
parce que le point le plus marquant le
point le plus un peu spectaculaire c'est
quand que l'auris s'est présenté en
compagnie de grégory moulis à bord de sa
ferrari aux funérailles d'un air aux
roses eric vite you vient de prendre sa
retraite de la police de montréal où il
était l'un des spécialistes en
renseignements sur le crime organisé
je pense que ça a été un plus le moment
fort de ma gauche je pense que sur ça a
été comme un petit peu la goutte qui
fait déborder le barreau qui sont ces
deux hommes à cette époque greggory
bouli vient de sortir de prison et il
est considéré comme le chef des gangs de
rue autrefois membre d'un club école des
hells angels
il devient un proche de maurice boucher
le chef dr
à l'époque il a été accusé d'un meurtre
sanglant survenu en pleine course de
noël sur la rue sainte catherine
en 1996 il en a été acquitté mais quatre
ans plus tard il est condamné il passera
né en prison pour sa participation à la
guerre des motards et son compagnon pour
les funérailles
et nul autre que loris cavalière
l'avocat du clan rizutto d'art présente
l alliance des italiens des gangs de rue
puis des moteurs tout le monde ensemble
puis la pierre angulaire des trous mais
évidemment c'était ma cavalière aucune
idée du jeu produit de preuve au palais
de justice où il pratique depuis des
décennies loris cavalière est reconnu
pour sa personnalité sympathique et son
ouverture au compromis même par les
policiers qui arrêtaient ses clients
dans le jeu de 10 contacts dans le
milieu policier loris c'était un
gentleman il avait toujours une façon de
régler avec avec l'auris par la
discussion
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette présence décomplexée de mettre
loris cavalière dans des événements liés
au crime organisé
envoie un autre signal clair aux
policiers m cavalière n'est plus
seulement un avocat qui défend les
droits des gangsters
il semble être lui même devenu un
gangster
pour une rare fois dans l'histoire du
pays la police va mettre des micros dans
un cabinet d'avocats est celui qui mène
l'équipe qui posera ses micros pour la
police c'est lui l'immeuble qui a ciblé
c'est un immeuble à deux étages au
rez-de-chaussée on y retrouve un
commerce de vêtements et à l'étagé on y
retrouve le cabinet d'avocats les agents
devront entrer de nuit dans le cabinet
il personne ne doit s'en rendre compte
[Musique]
ce soit le lieu visé est situé sur une
rue qui était quand même assez passante
un quartier dans lequel de certains
restaurants et les lieux commerciaux
mais aussi des résidences qui sont à
proximité du lieux visés et on est à
période quand même estivale
ton
ce soir-là de juin 2014
plusieurs agents en civil surveillent le
secteur les personnes qui font une
entrée subreptice qui vont avoir la
responsabilité d'installer des
dispositifs d'écouté électronique
donc il se concentre à 100% sur cette
tâche là donc ils ne peuvent pas
regarder aussi de répondre dans leur dos
pour moi c'est quelqu'un qui vont des
centrales qui vaut ce site est incertain
des risques au procès
[Musique]
martin dubois ne peut nous révéler tous
les secrets de l'opération mais l'équipe
réussit à contourner les systèmes de
sécurité est entrée dans le cabinet
[Musique]
à l'intérieur les policiers repèrent
d'abord les lieux pour déterminer avec
les enquêteurs au dossier où ils vont
placer les micros l'équipe d'accueil
bonne visite en chine selon les
renseignements qu'ils ont à leur
disposition
quels sont les endroits qu'ils veulent
cibler qui vont être le plus avantageux
pour intensité comme cas sont privés
les agents vont placer un micro à la
réception du cabinet dans le bureau
personnel de loris cavalière dans la
salle de conférence
retenez cette information cela deviendra
important plus tard il faudra plusieurs
entrées aux policiers pour compléter
l'installation chaque fois avec les
risques que ça comporte quand seront
dans un bulletin publié un outil là à
droite et je pense que la personne
reviennent dans sa résidence le la main
qui trouve elle parle d'à peine sous une
peau veine de filou à terre et à l'isro
que quelqu'un qui peuvent être ni si
jamais loris cavalière ne réalisera que
son cabinet sous écoute ainsi la police
va découvrir le rôle d'un deuxième
avocat qui a traversé la ligne
dans un instant va faire entendre des
conversations troublante de ses membres
du crime organisé qui se croyaient bien
à l'abri dans un cabinet d'avocats le
but d'échapper à toute forme d'encart
toute forme des côtes possible
jusqu'ici tout va bien pour la police
après plusieurs entrées secrètes ils ont
réussi à mettre leurs micros dans le
cabinet d'avocats mais ils vont devoir
prendre beaucoup de précautions avec ces
enregistrements au quartier général de
la gendarmerie royale du canada à
montréal
un agent de police quitte avec une
enveloppe un colis qui pourrait s'avérer
précieux pour les enquêteurs du projet
magot menée par là et ce qu appuyé de la
grc
le policier message et se rend au palais
de justice de québec où se trouve la
juge qui doit écouter les premières
conversations enregistrées chez
cavalière et associés les policiers ont
vu entrer au cabinet ce qu'ils croient
être des dirigeants du crime organisé
ce qui unissent les gangs de rue la
mafia qui rigolent les roulis stéphane
au sol et tito et leonardo risotto mais
les policiers n'ont encore rien dégoûté
la juge doit décider à quoi ils auront
accès c'est elle la gardienne du secret
professionnel
nous demandons à m marie pierre boulet
avocat criminaliste de nous expliquer
pourquoi le secret professionnel est
aussi sacrée dans notre système de
justice
je pense que le meilleur exemple c'est
de revenir dans la peau d'une personne
qui va se faire arrêter
on nous prend on nous sort de notre vie
on nous amène dans un poste de police
on nous détient et l'on est privé de
tout le monde extérieur on va avoir le
droit à un appel que ça c'est le droit à
l'avocat
mais si cet appel au final et écouter ou
peut être utilisé une seringue
il ya quand même quelques exceptions
secret professionnel le statut d'avocat
ne confère pas une protection absolue m
matthew ferguson et procureurs à la
direction des poursuites criminelles et
pénales
l'exception c'est lorsqu'il ya des
motifs raisonnables de croire que la bac
a lui même participé à une infraction
criminelle ou est sur le point de
participer à une effraction qui menace
puisque loris cavalière est soupçonné de
participer à un crime
une juge a autorisé l'interception des
communications
mais c'est un exercice très délicat
quand c'est un avocat
les policiers doit avait en fait l'état
doit prendre des mesures des précautions
supplémentaires pour minimiser le plus
possible
l'intrusion ou de porter atteinte au
secret professionnel de l'avocat qui ne
protège pas l'avocat mais qui protège
des clients légitimes que font les
policiers pour satisfaire cette exigence
concrètement les policiers enregistrent
mais n'écoute pas tout de suite
on n'a pas à se questionner à savoir si
une conversation est réellement une
conversation qui se déroule entre un
avocat et son client ou s'ils sont en
train de parler d'eux dans le jeu ou
golf ou d'aller installer
donc quand nous aurons tous et donc qui
prend part à une conversation on doit
automatiquement en action et traiter
cette conversation la com et à
privilégier des conversations qui sont
brûlés sur un dvd qui sont mis dans un
sac scellés sont transportés par un
politique qui n'est pas impliquée dans
la cahute équilibre physiquement les
livres et le sax aller aux juges pour
que le juge puisse prendre connaissance
des conversations
le juge fera connaissance de
conversation et vos des récits vous
m'indiquer sur un tableau qui lui a été
fournie
quelles sont les conditions qui sont
privilégiés quels sont les conversations
qui sont non privilégiés à chaque
semaine de nouveaux enregistrements sont
envoyés à la juge qui libère à la pièce
des conversations qui ont lieu chez
cavalière et associe les policiers
entrent ainsi dans le secret du cabinet
notamment dans la salle de conférences
qui tu es ici haute et ruelles au dessus
du garage derrière ses fenêtres
le sens des extraits que vous entendrez
est interprété par les policiers il
détermine également qui parle
nous sommes levés ou 2015 à 14h48 le
même jour deux autres suspects de
l'enquète arrive dans la salle de
conférence grégory moulis que vous
connaissez déjà et un certain stéphane
soler cetto
les policiers ont déjà appris en cours
d' enquêtes qu'ils habitent dans cette
luxueuse résidence de mascouche qu'ils
déclarent des revenus d'environ 25000
dollars par année mais qu'il a aussi
joué pour deux millions et demi de
dollars sur deux ans au casino de
montréal
pas mal pour un vendeur de céramique
mais la police pense qu'il trempe dans
un autre commerce beaucoup plus violent
[Applaudissements]
pour les enquêteurs il ne fait pas de
doute que les hommes par d'éliminer un
membre de l'organisation qui n'ont plus
confiance changeait pas mais richert et
leur conversation se poursuit
[Musique]
quelques mois après ses conversations le
19 novembre 2015 les policy face à
l'action ils arrêtent une vingtaine de
personnes dont seules et shito on lit
rizutto et l'avocat cavalière les hauts
gradés des corps de police impliqués
dans le projet magot convoque la presse
pour se féliciter de l'opération nous
sommes extrêmement fiers des résultats
de cette opération majeure
elle porte un grand coup au crime
organisé au québec mais également à
l'échelle du pays
nous attaquons bouteille dirigeants
d'une alliance en trois importantes
souche le crime organisé qui contrôle
notamment le trafic de drogue le
blanchiment d'argent sur le territoire
de montréal et ses environs
en gros c'est ça c'était le contrôle
total de plusieurs secteurs de montréal
ou au niveau du trafic de stupéfiants et
une toute toute les profits étaient
divisés avec cette alliance et toutes
les décision est prise par cette
alliance et les policiers sont
convaincus d'une chose
l'utilisation d'un bureau d'avocats pour
discuter des affaires de leur empire
criminel faisait partie de la stratégie
du suspect le bureau de monsieur
cavaliere est accusé comme le bureau
central de l'alien toutes les décisions
cruciales était faite à son bureau
donc le bureau était utilisé en soit
comme un bouclier juridique dans
plusieurs enquêtes auxquelles j'ai
participé
évidemment l'iran qu'on se font dans des
bureaux d'avocats j'ai contrôlé des
sources qui monte gicler rencontre
faisait dans les bureaux d'avocats corps
dans sa carrière de policier éric vécu
ou étaient branchés sur des acteurs du
crime organisé
certains lui on confie que les
rencontres illicites dans des cabinets
d'avocats
c'est un grand classique mais en fait
l'avocat et le privilège te donne une
certaine immunité par rapport à des
actions policières qui pourraient être
entreprises contre l'organisation
évidemment si c'est fait dans des lieux
où au nom de l'avocat mais il ya une
certaine immunité l'immunité qui est
donnée à l'avocat est automatiquement
transféré à l'organisation criminelle
si l'avocat est assez proche de cette
organisation là pour leur permettre de
profiter un peu de ces de cette immunité
l'eau le but d'échapper à toute toute
forme de dents car toute forme de
découpe possible je vous dis pas que
c'est impossible on dit que c'est
beaucoup plus facile d'aller mettre un
micro dans un dans un bar à lait des le
maire d'agen un bureau d'avocats et
loris cavalière prêté son cabinet à des
criminels en le croyant inviolable
d'autant plus qu'il y à un autre
distingués membres du baron parmi les
suspects leonardo résout taux est aussi
avocat y cela viendra beaucoup compliqué
les choses
dans un instant vous raconte comment le
fils du parrain de la mafia
même avec des antécédents judiciaires
ont réussi à devenir avocat et à quel
point ça va lui être utile
c'est pas la première fois qu'on voit
des avocats se réfugier derrière la
muraille constitutionnel secret
professionnel pour faire des complots
alors est ce que vous croyez que les
carottes sont cuites pour leonardo
risotto et ses coaccusés vous risquez
d'avoir une surprise et vous risquez
d'être encore plus surpris quand vous
allez apprendre ce que le barreau du
québec a fait dans le dos et de risotto
qui je vous le rappelle est décrit comme
une tête dirigeante de la mafia
[Musique]
loris cavalière est arrivé au palais de
justice ce matin avec sa petite valise
labié confortablement prêt à aller en
prison
il a décidé d'admettre qu'il a traversé
la ligne
il plaide coupable de gangstérisme et de
possession d'une arme à feu
il a été condamné à trente quatre mois
de prison
il a par la suite été radié par le
barreau
quant à leonardo résout tôt il est
toujours membre du barreau est
littéralement derrière les barreaux
c'est ici et la prison bordeaux qu'il
attend depuis plus de deux ans son
procès pour gangstérisme et complot pour
trafic de cocaïne avec six coaccusés
stéphane au sol et tito et grégory
moulis rizutto va se battre il a plaidé
non coupable mais cela semble mal parti
pour le juge qui a refusé de le remettre
en liberté
à écouter une partie des conversations
captées chez cavalière et associés il
écrit au sujet de risotto et soul et
shito les conversations des montres de
positionnement des deux détenus dans
l'organisation ce sont des décideurs
l'ensemble de ces conversations établi
un contexte de criminalité dont il n'est
pas permis de douter
à cette étape le juge ne fait qu'une
appréciation à première vue de la preuve
mais leonardo rizutto à un as dans sa
manche ou dans sa toge il va mener une
bataille au nom du secret professionnel
il est avocat et cela va beaucoup lui
servir
même si son accession au barreau a été
compliqué
[Musique]
à l'époque de cette vidéo familiale chez
les résultats en 1995
leonardo à 26 ans un bac en droit et une
rutilante corvette
leonardo rizutto s'y est pris à
plusieurs reprises pour tenter d effet
son droit mais l'école du barreau le
refusaient pas parce que c'était le fils
de vito rizutto pour officiellement en
tout cas mais parce que il accumulé les
condamnations d'abord ivresse au volant
deux joueurs le chroniqueur yves
boisvert de la presse a raconté toutes
les péripéties de leonardo rizutto dans
sa quête pour devenir avocat son permis
de conduire a été suspendu de façon
presque ininterrompue pendant sept ans
il continuer à conduire s'est fait
arrêté dix fois pour ollanta corvette en
conduisant sans permis et donc le
barreau a dit écoutez vous avez un
mépris total pour la loi vous n'avez pas
les moeurs et la conduite et les
qualités nécessaires qui est un critère
dans la loi pour faire partie de notre
profession est donc on vous rejette
leonardo rizutto conteste son avocat dit
que c'était au fond de façon hypocrite
d'exclure le fils du parrain et gagne
leonardo rizutto devient avocat à sa
troisième tentative il vingt ans plus
tard
si trop va beaucoup lui servir
retour au palais de justice où le projet
magot doit subir le test des tribunaux
grégory moulis leonardo rizutto et
stefano folli chito invoque la violation
du secret professionnel pour faire
tomber la preuve notamment parce que la
police a eu accès à des conversations
qu'ils ne devaient pas écoutés au
cabinet de loris cavalière
souvenons nous que la police a mis des
micros un peu partout dans le cabinet
dans le bureau personnel de loris
cavalière à la réception et dans une
salle de conférence
cela a plus tard causé la perte de la
poursuite représentée par m mature
ferguson c'est l'eau au lieu des
problèmes si niveau delà de la mise en
application depuis la mise en exécution
du du monde des contes électroniques
c'est-à-dire la façon dont les des
renseignements les communications ont
été interceptés dans une décision
étoffer le juge eric dans sa tranchée
lorsque résout tous et soly tito discuté
dans le bureau de loris cavalière les
fautes était légale mais à la réception
et à la salle de conférence c'était
illégal conclut juge parce que il la
salle servait à la fois des rencontres
qu'on estimait criminelle en nature et
des rencontres qui étaient tout à fait
légitimes
pourquoi parce que solitude tout est à
l'époque de l'anc est un client du
cabinet quelques leonardo résultats et
avocats qui donne l'adresse de cavalière
et associés comme places d'affaires
professionnels
la poursuite en caisse le coin l'effet
de cette décision sur l'exclusion de
cette preuve là
faire en sorte que la poursuivante la
poursuite n'était pas en mesure de faire
la preuve et s'amener un acquittement
dans le dossier leonardo et utp et
stéphane au sol et tito ont gagné ils
ont invoqué le secret professionnel avec
succès ce que la police décrivait comme
les têtes dirigeantes de la mafia
italienne sont acquittés de gangstérisme
et de complot pour trafic de drogue
une décision très bien accueilli par les
avocats de la défense
le public et protégée comme un état
policier quand des policiers qui
pourrait simplement surveiller la envie
donc je pense que le public de la façon
qu'ils doivent recevoir ce qui les
protège et grégory moulis demandé aussi
le rejet des côtes électronique mais il
a perdu parce qu'il n'est ni client ni
avocat en d'autres termes il n'avait
aucune raison légitime de se trouver au
cabinet d'avocats il sera condamné en
2008 à 8 en prison
ce raisonnement démontre clairement que
leonardo rizutto a bénéficié d'un
traitement différent parce qu'il est
avocat mais il n'est pas encore tiré
d'affaires en cours de cette enquête les
policiers ont effectué plusieurs
perquisitions principalement dans la
grande région de montréal
c'est leonardo rizutto 5 grammes de
cocaïne et deux armes de poing ont été
saisis dont celle ci avec un numéro de
série oblitéré
il sera acquitté à nouveau une juge
conclut que le mandat de perquisition
était illégal parce qu'ils découlent de
l' écoute illégale chez cavalière et
associés l'acquittement est en appel
c'est pas la première fois qu'on voit
des avocats se réfugier derrière la
muraille constitutionnelle du secret
professionnel
alors c'est clair que d'avoir un membre
d'une organisation criminelle qui a sa
licence d'avocat
c'est un gros avantage parce que là ça
revient à l'état de démontrer qu'ils se
serrent de 7 de son permis d'avocats
pour commettre des crimes pour faciliter
des crémants l'ex-policier eric vecchio
aimerait qu'on tire des leçons de la
sphère rizutto mais un moment donné il
faut aussi se il faut aussi se rendre
compte que certains avocats
malheureusement franchissent la ligne
caen qu'il franchisse la ligne est ce
qu'on devrait toujours vouloir accorder
ce privilège là c'est la question qu'il
faudrait poser mais un fait est
particulièrement troublant dans le
parcours judiciaire de leonardo rizutto
nous retournons à la décision du juge
qui a refusé de le remettre en liberté
au moment de son arrestation
âgé de 46 ans monsieur rizutto avocat de
formation n'exerce plus depuis plusieurs
années leonardo rizutto à le titre
d'avocat mais ils ne pratiquent pas le
beurre et l'argent du beurre
un traitement différent devant la
justice en raison de son statut d'avocat
alors qu'il ne donne même pas de conseil
juridique d'ailleurs grégory moulis ont
amusé dans l'écouté électronique au
cabinet de loris cavalière
grégory moulis ne trouve pas le bureau
de risotto parce qu'il n'a pas de vrais
bureaux ses cavalières et associés mais
ça fait un peu drôle quand même du fait
qu'il dise pas moi je savais où je paye
mes cotisations je suis dans un bureau
je je je fait bénéficier à mes clients
qui sont des criminels et dont je sais
qui écoeure dedans que ge a aidé à
commettre leurs crimes
je leur fait bénéficier de mon secret
professionnel mais moi je pratique pas
soit c'est très particulier dame non
seulement leonardo rizutto est il libre
comme l'air mais oui bonjour j'aimerais
dire ici c'est un avocat et membre en
règle du barreau nous vérifions s'il est
toujours avocat maître leonardo risotto
mais at il au moins été sanctionné nous
appelons greffe de discipline du barreau
rien du tout non je vous remercie
depuis plusieurs semaines nous tenterons
d'interviewer paul mathieu grondin le
bâtonnier du québec et porte-parole du
barreau nous avions des questions
notamment sur le cas rizutto tous les
dossiers du syndic ou l'instance de
discipline du barreau sont
confidentielles nous at on répondu par
courriel
pour moi c'est honteux que le barreau ne
prennent aucune mesure pour faire en
sorte qu'une personne dont on connaît
les activités criminelles soient encore
membre de sa profession
et ça ça revient au syndic du barreau la
police l'accusé ait eu une erreur
et puis a été acquitté mais cette preuve
là elle existe quand même
hélas ce qui est arrivé c'est qu'on a
importé en droit professionnel des
notions de droit criminel l'exclusion de
la preuve pourquoi l exclusion de la
preuve
parce qu'on veut que l'état soit fair
play et tu sois honnête avec eux la
police warnet et que parce que les
conséquences sont énormes on envoie
quelqu'un en prison mais est membre
d'une profession d'un privilège s'éprend
un droit nous avons appelé leonardo
rizutto ou numéro qui apparaît dans le
bottin des avocats du barreau
oui bonjour m riou tous je m'appelle
marie maude denis je suis journaliste
élections en cas elle par radio canada
nous lui avons aussi envoyé un courriel
nous n'avons reçu aucune réponse
le barreau représente les avocats ou
représente la société
elle protège qui 2 qui pourra se poser
la question
même si le barreau a entre autres pour
mission de protéger le public
il est hors de question de parler de ces
questions en public dans la suite de
notre enquête on va rester dans le
domaine des avocats on va bifurquer un
peu pour parler du rôle d avocate
d'affaires et de blanchiment d'argent
plusieurs millions étaient déposés dans
les comptes entrust du désir et de
dizaines d'avocats et plus dans la jante
en tout
on va maintenant s'intéresser aux
avocate d'affaires ceux qui sont dans le
domaine financier par exemple ceux qui
créent des compagnies vous allez voir
que pour la police c'est pas évident
d'enquêter sur non plus et que dans le
domaine de la lutte au blanchiment
d'argent on peut aussi questionner le
rôle de surveillance du barreau
le baron refuse de nous parler du cas de
m leonardo rizutto mais on a d'autres
questions pour le bateau ni que fait
l'ordre professionnel pour empêcher les
avocats de participer au blanchiment
d'argent
ils les inciter à lutter contre ce fléau
parce que dix avocats qui traverse la
ligne
il y en a aussi dans le monde financier
par exemple cet homme qui fuit la caméra
c'est jacques matte le dérange avocat au
québec avoir été condamné à la prison
pour blanchiment d'argent
son histoire recoupe plusieurs éléments
qui font réfléchir
nous y reviendrons mais d'abord un peu
de contexte
dans la foulée des attentats du 11
septembre 2001 plusieurs pays ont durci
leurs lois sur le financement du
terrorisme et le recyclage des produits
de la criminalité ou blanchiment
d'argent pour faire plus simple dont le
canada
mais sur le principe je pense présenter
aujourd'hui
d'autant qu'à mes yeux législatives
qu'il dise on conseille notre sécurité
nationale
au départ les avocats comme plusieurs
professionnels ont de nouvelles
obligations comme de déclarer les
transactions douteuses de leurs clients
l'objet du régime est selon nous un
constitutionnel tout autant que les
effets mais les avocats dénoncent
jusqu'en cour suprême ce régime qui
selon lui porte atteinte à leurs
privilèges et leurs devoirs envers leurs
clients ils vont gagner
résultat ils n'ont plus l'obligation de
déclarer les opérations qui soulève des
drapeaux rouges
l'addition est un collègue c'est pas
juste je sais qu ils ont besoin d'être
surveillés les avocats comme toutes les
autres industries tous les autres
secteurs qui ont des obligations pour la
prévention du blanchiment d'argent
denis meunier a été le directeur adjoint
de cannes à l' agence gouvernementale
qui surveille les transactions douteuses
il a aussi des directeurs des enquêtes
criminelles à revenu canada
c'est sûr que la grande majorité des
avocats sont honnêtes sont intègres
par contre le risque de vulnérabilité au
blanchiment d'argent et est allé
particulièrement élevé lorsqu'ils sont
impliquées dans des transactions
immobilières ou encore lors de la
création de compagnies ou de fiducie la
victoire des avocats en cour suprême
nuit à la lutte au blanchiment d'argent
et même à la réputation mondiale du
canada comme le reconnaît ce rapport de
2018 du ministère des finances
le canada et les états unis sont les
deux seuls pays du g7 qui n'ont pas de
réglementation de l'eau
qui s'applique directement aux avocats
les barreaux canadiens ont convaincu la
cour suprême qu'il pouvait s'auto
surveiller est ce que le barreau est un
vrai chien de garde
revenons au cas de l'avocat jacques
matte il est d'abord éclaboussé dans la
fraude du marché central dans les années
90 mais il n'est pas accusé
le barreau ne bouge pas en 2007 jacques
matte est condamné au civil pour son
rôle dans une fraude immobilière de
plusieurs millions de dollars
l'année suivante la presse évoque de
nouveau jacques matte dans le scandale
jitec que fera le barreau avant de vous
donner la réponse nous rencontrons
quelqu'un qui en connaît long en matière
d' enquêtes sur la criminalité
financière
mon équipe on a travaillé pendant près
de 4 ha sur une enquête de blanchiment
d'argent qui qui était une enquête
majeure je dirais qu'il touchait
plusieurs plusieurs pays
françois olivier millet a dirigé le
projet collector de la grc qui a mené à
une vingtaine d'arrestations en 2019
[Musique]
on voit ici un échange un échange
d'argent sale
entre deux suspects captées par une
caméra de la police et la grc a suivi la
trace de l'argent
sans rentrer dans les détails de l'anc
est pas ce qu il faut savoir que c'est
un dossier qui est présentement devant
les tribunes où je pourrais vous dire
que plusieurs centaines de millions
étaient blanchis par l'organisation et
plusieurs millions ont été déposés dans
des comptes entrust une dirait d'une
dizaine d'avocats et plus dans la région
de toronto
les comptines trust ou compte en
fidéicommis
ce sont les comptes de banques ou les
avocats peuvent notamment verser
l'argent de leurs clients
ces comptes sont aussi couverts par le
secret professionnel et cite un trou
noir pour la police tout comme pour
perquisitionner un bureau d'avocats
offert une ordonnance de communication
dans le compte bancaire
in trust en fils ici d'un avocat
constituerait une fouille une fouille
illégale si on veut donc malheureusement
ne peut pas demander à une banque de
nous produire les informations bancaires
d'un compte en fidéicommis
sauf si la police peut d'abord prouver
que l'avocat c'est qu'il commet un crime
cet immeuble du centre ville de montréal
est au centre d'une grosse transaction
qui nous ramène à jacques matte s'est
notamment moyen de ses comptes en
fidéicommis qu'il a fait transiter des
millions de dollars pour réaliser ce qui
sera décrit par un tribunal en 2008
comme une fraude mais comme il s'agit
d'un jugement civil et non criminelle le
barreau affirmé en entrevue à la presse
qu'il ne peut pas sévir 2009 jacques
matte est toujours avocats lorsque son
conduit les soeurs et perquisitionné par
là et ce qu dans la sphère speedo matt a
aidé le dirigeant de l'entreprise de
services financiers speedo ronald
chicoine a monté une opération de
blanchiment d'argent et de fraude
fiscale de dizaines de millions de
dollars
enfin le barreau annonce qu'il agira
contre jacques matte
mais celui ci remet sa démission plus de
dix ans après les premières allégations
de comportement doute
contre lui dans la sphère speedo jacques
matte a fini par plaider coupable en
2014 de gangstérisme de fraude et de
blanchiment d'argent
il a été condamné à 36 mois de prison
nous lui avons à faire une entrevue il
offre toujours des services de fiscalité
et donne l'adresse de cette prestigieuse
tours à bureaux de westmount seulement
cinq professionnels incluant jacques
matte ont été condamnés dans la sphère
speedo mais en consultant les documents
de l' enquête nous avons découvert que
l'argent de l'arnaqué a transité par les
comptes en fidéicommis de pas moins de
soixante cinq avocats et notaires du
québec
la très grande majorité d'entre eux n'a
pas eu de compte à rendre
nous avons demandé plusieurs fois à paul
mathieu grondin l'actuel bâtonnier du
québec de nous accorder une entrevue le
bar on nous a répondu qu'il n'avait pas
le temps
avant même de nous demander quand nous
voulions le rencontrer oui bonjour je
m'appelle marie maude denis chef de
l'émission enquête à radio canada
j'aimerais vraiment vraiment parler au
bâtonnier maître paul mathieu grondin
vous le savez ça fait plusieurs fois que
je laisse des messages
on nous a informés par écrit que le
barreau avait adopté de nouvelles règles
pour ses avocats donner des formations
mener des inspections notamment
comptable auprès de ses membres
le barreau souligne aussi qu'il a
épinglé quelques uns de ses membres pour
des opérations irrégulières en argent
comptant dans leurs comptes en
fidéicommis de 9000 $ jusqu'à 3 millions
six cent mille dollars pour ses fautes
le barreau a imposé des sanctions allant
de la simple réprimande à une radiation
temporaire de quatre mois denis meunier
est loin d'être convaincu
c'est le ballon qui fait select c'est le
boulot qui fait ses preuves et
d'inspection qui enquête sur ces
placements
il ya un manque de transparence par au
public sur les résultats de ces
inspections
et puis finalement les sanctions à mon
avis ne sont pas assez dissuasives
souvent critiqué policiers parce qu'ils
font il ya enquête sur l'humain c'est la
même chose avec le barreau ce sont des
avocats qui enquêtent sur des avocats
[Musique]
vous l'avez vu dans le reportage ça fait
cinq ans depuis cette fameuse décision
de la cour suprême et deux puissants
leur gouvernement canadien dit qu'il
veut trouver un moyen d'obliger les
avocats à lutter plus efficacement
contre le blanchiment d'argent
alors on a voulu savoir où on en était
dans ce dossier réponse du cabinet de la
ministre des finances
on a créé un groupe de réflexion avec
les associations d'avocats
bref aucune mesure concrète pour le
moment
[Musique]
j'espère que vous avez apprécié de
reportages de ce soir au nom de toute
l'équipe merci beaucoup d'avoir été là
je vous donne rendez vous la semaine
prochaine pour une autre enquête
je
[Musique]